hi i'm beau with freecodecamp.org
by the end of this course you will know
how to make all of these different
websites and how to customize them we'll
be doing this all in wordpress and i'm
going to teach you every step you need
to know
this course is perfect for beginners
first i'll show you how to do the
initial setup this includes getting a
domain name hosting and installing
wordpress a domain name is what people
type into a web browser to get to your
website some examples are youtube.com
freecodecamp.org or wordpress.org
hosting is where the files or data for
your website are stored when someone
goes to your website the files that make
up your website have to be accessed from
another computer somewhere else in the
world
the company that has the computer with
your website files on it is called a
hosting provider
so what is wordpress
wordpress is a content management system
it helps you manage your content
basically it helps you create a website
even if you know nothing about coding
you don't need to know html css or
javascript you can do everything
graphically with wordpress
wordpress is by far the most popular way
to make a website it is used by forty
percent of all websites and best of all
wordpress is free to use
after we get the wordpress software
installed i'll show you how to set up
the installation and customize it for
your purposes
maybe you want to make the website into
a blog or an e-commerce site or a
website for a local business
i'll show you how you can easily
customize it for whatever your use case
is
then i'll show you how to update the
design
i'll show you how you can make your
website have the exact look that you
want it to have
i'll show you how to get your own images
into the page and use the colors that
you want
right now i'm going to show you how to
get your domain and your hosting
this is the part that you will have to
pay some money for but it is pretty
cheap
the name usually costs between 10 and
twenty dollars per year and hosting
often costs around five dollars per
month but i'll show you how you can save
some money on this
we'll actually get the domain and
hosting at the same place
hostinger provided free codecamp a grant
to make this course possible and we'll
use hostinger to get the domain and
hosting
they're one of the cheapest hosting
providers and they have good service
i've actually used them in the past for
my personal websites before we got this
grant
and they make it super simple to set up
a wordpress website
just so you know everything i teach in
this course will work with other hosting
providers as well so you don't have to
go with hostinger
but some things about hosinger is that
they offer a free domain ssl and 99
uptime guarantee
so we'll go to hostinger.com we have a
link in the description that's going to
give you a better deal than what you
would normally get so click go for it
we'll go down here and we have we have
the single shared hosting and the
premium shared hosting
now
if you're just go if you're just
starting out you're a beginner you may
just want to go with the single shared
hosting the cheapest one the main thing
to look at is really really the main
thing is that this one comes with a free
domain and this one does not come with a
free domain but it's just an 8.99 value
so if you get
this version you can just get the domain
separately for 8.99 or possibly a little
more depending on what your your uh
whether it's me a com or a dotnet or
what the the end of the domain is
different types of domains cost
different amounts but they're generally
around 8.99 so you may just want to go
with this one this 99 99 cents a month
and then just pay for the domain
separately instead of doing this one
that's 219 a month but you can see that
this is just the promotional rate
anyways it's going to be 4.99 a month
when you renew or 2.99
per month when you renew so you just you
really want to kind of look at what the
real rate is and not just a promotional
rate
so if we select this one right here
and then you're gonna actually have to
choose whether you want to go with the
one month pay by month or pay by
12 months 24 months or 48 months you can
see that the 99 the 99 price is only for
48 months personally i think the 12
months is the most reasonable especially
when you're just starting out uh you
don't want to commit to 48 months unless
you're sure you're going to want to use
this for
actually that long so i'll just go to
the 12 month plan
and then you can just choose how you
want to pay for it
and then enter all your information
now i already have an account so i'm not
going to enter all my information right
here i'm just going to log into my
account where i already have everything
set up
so once you get signed up and you've
paid and you're logged in you'll be
taken to this dashboard
and
if you got the plan that includes a free
domain you can claim your free domain or
you can just get your domain during the
setup process including purchasing one
if your plan does not come with a free
domain
this is what we are going to do so i'll
click setup under premium shared hosting
okay welcome to hosinger quincy my name
is actually beau
but quincy larson is also with free
codecamp and this account is actually in
his name so i'll click start now
okay here we get to choose what type of
category you're in either you're
claiming a free domain because you have
the right type of hosting or account to
get that you're going to buy a domain
because maybe you sign up for the
account that doesn't include a free
domain but you still need one or you're
going to use an existing domain first
i'll show you how to claim a domain
the process is similar if you're going
to buy a domain
afterwards i will show you how to use an
existing domain
so i'm going to try
dot
robotoysreview.com
okay that's available you may have to
try a few times to get a domain name
that's available because a lot of domain
names already taken
but let me hit continue here
and then i am going to
skip i will start from scratch
and i can choose my website location
let's do north america
because that's where i am at
finish setup
okay my website is ready now i'm going
to go to the control panel i'm going to
manage manage the site
and if you somehow get out of it and
you're at this main site you can always
go to hosting and then you can go to
manage for your manage your website here
before i show you how to manage your
domain and setup wordpress let me show
you how you can use a domain purchased
elsewhere
it's easiest to get your domain and your
hosting from the same company however
it's not required you can get your
domain from one company and host your
website with a different company so let
me show you how you would host a website
on hostinger if you got your domain from
a different company now you can just
skip this section if you're just going
the easy route you're just getting
everything from hostinger but if for
some reason you do get a domain from
somewhere else i'll show you how you can
set it up so host so you're hosting it
at hostinger so in this example i got a
domain called robotfamilyreviews.com
from google domains no matter where you
get your domain there's going to be
somewhere in the dashboard where you can
update the name servers it could be
under something called dns it could just
be under something called name servers
so we're going to have to update that in
order to make sure that we're hosting
this name with hostinger so i'm going to
go to use custom name servers and it
could look a little different depending
on what company you bought the name
server
what the company bought the domain name
from but it's going to be pretty similar
to this so i'm going to put
ns1.dnsparking.com
this name server this website here is
specific to hostinger so
this is something owned by hostinger and
this it's how you connect your domain to
hostinger so i'm actually going to copy
this i'll click save
and i'm going to oh i have to add
another one so i'm going to press plus
and then i'm going to do ns2
so
these are the website
ns1.dns-parking.comns2.dnsparking.com
so these if i save this
now it says it could take
effect within the next 48 hours so it
could take a but it may be this day and
maybe in the next hour or two
so it's going to take a little while for
it to be connected correctly but now
we've done everything from our domain to
get this connected to hostinger
a little later i'll show you one extra
thing you have to do on hostinger to
make sure it's connected to this domain
okay now we're completely logged into
our hosting account it's associated with
our website and now we have to install
wordpress
and just in case you want to use a
different domain name let me show you
how you would do that now you probably
won't want to do that you'll probably
want to just use the domain name that
you got with hostinger but if you do get
another domain name and you want to make
sure it works with the files that you're
hosting on hostinger i'll show you what
you can do you can scroll down here and
we'll go to add website and i'm just
going to add
another website that that i purchased
elsewhere so you can actually have a
website that's from elsewhere that from
a different company go to the hostinger
hosting so i'm gonna do robot
familyreviews.com
and make sure it's spelled right
and then we'll do a password
[Music]
and then add the website
so that's one cool thing about hostinger
is if depending on what plan you have if
you have the right plan you can host
multiple websites on one account so you
only have to pay for hosting one time
and then you can host a bunch of
websites on there so then this drop down
menu would point to which up what's
website you're going to update so i'm
going to robot family reviews
and so since i set the dns settings to
hostinger i'm at
robotfamilyreviews.com and this is just
the default page that hosting or is
before you set that up
so let's go back and set up the page so
it doesn't matter if you
got your domain name right through
hostinger or if you got it somewhere
else and then pointed it at hostinger we
are going to set up wordpress right now
so in order to set up wordpress i'm
going to scroll down here and then i'm
going to go to
auto installer this is going to let me
auto install wordpress
on the website okay you're probably not
going to see anything right here because
you probably don't have wordpress
already installed but if you've already
resto installed wordpress on any of your
domains it will show up here but this is
how you installed wordpress for the
first time on one of your domains
probably just one domain so we have we
can click that we want to install we
want to select that we want to install
wordpress there are also a few other
things that we can install like if you
are going to have an e-commerce site you
may want woocommerce as well but we're
just going to install wordpress
okay and you'll probably just want to
keep the default for all of this but
since this account was actually
registered to quincy and my name is bo
i'm going to update this to bow
but again you'll probably just keep the
default and everything else we can keep
the default i'll put in a password here
[Music]
and then the website title it's going to
be called robot family reviews
okay and i'll just click install
okay it's finished installing so i'm
going to go to my website again and i'm
going to refresh
and here it is robot family reviews we
have our wordpress installed go here you
can see the url up here robot family
reviews
and it says hello world welcome to
wordpress i'm going to zoom in a little
bit so you can see that better this is
just the default page that wordpress
creates
so we're going to do a lot of
customizing to this but we can see that
we have it successfully
installed okay so let me show you how
we're gonna get into our wordpress
dashboard to start editing it you we
don't even have to go back to the
hostinger website right from this
website we're gonna go into the url bar
and i'm going to put slash wp dash admin
so on most wordpress websites
the url slash wp-admin
is where you go to administer and be the
administrator for the website or to
configure the website
so let me press enter here
and now we have to log in we'll log in
with the information we use when we
created when we installed wordpress so
for my username i'll put bo and the
password
will be the password i selected before
click login
we are in
our wordpress dashboard so here is where
we can start customizing our website
we've finished setting up the website
and hosting we got the domain name we
got wordpress on installed on the
hosting provider we logged into the
dashboard now we're going to start
setting up and customizing the wordpress
options
so what we're going to go do first is go
to the plugins here and see what
installed plugins we have so you can see
there are quite a few things already
installed
and the truth is we're just going to
start from scratch a lot of these uh
default plugins aren't really that
necessary because they may not really
specifically apply to what we're going
to try to do so i'm going to select all
the plugins here
i am going to
delete all of them
and i'm sure i wanted to delete them
and some i may have to oh some of them
i'm going to deactivate first so i'm
going to deactivate and apply
and now i will
delete all of them
don't worry because all these can be
reinstalled if you need them we're just
going to start from scratch and show
everything that we want to install all
the plugins that are going to work for
the page that we're creating here
so let's go back to the dashboard
and so here's our main dashboard
so this dashboard is the back end of the
website
it's where you control all the options
it's where you go to edit your website
and you can see whenever you want to see
your website
let me just show the different tabs up
here if i click robot family reviews
it's going to go right to the main
website where i can click back also if i
click here and click visit sites it's
going to go to the site
so first i want to show you before we
get into all the customizing i want to
show you how you would make sure you
have the most updated version of web of
wordpress so if you click updates here
right on the dashboard
we can see that there are nothing
there's nothing to update if there's
anything to update would say something
like update or there'll be a button
around here but we have the latest
version so we don't have to do anything
as far as updating but so you can keep
an eye on over time you you probably
want to get the latest version just in
case there's any security updates that
could be important to keeping your
website secure
okay now let's look at how we can
add a user or change the password of the
user so if i go to users here we have
currently one user
and it's bo and if i was gonna to change
the password i'll just click here go to
edit
and then there's all these things i can
change here
including setting a new password but i
like my password so we're not going to
do that
this is also where you can
add a new user if i click add new you
can have multiple users that can log in
to the administrator portion of your
wordpress page and each user could have
different roles so maybe one person can
only add new blog posts where another
person can actually redesign the whole
website depending on what what what
abilities you want to give to each user
okay next we're going to set up what the
urls of our pages and posts will look
like
so i'll go to settings here
and then i'm going to go to where it
says permalinks
okay so the default is that it's going
to
have your root url and it's going to be
slash index.psp
slash year slash month num and then we
don't want to have all this extra thing
so what i'm going to do is just change
it to post name so the url is just going
to be a url of something on our website
it's just going to be our root url
and then just sample dash post or this
would be just the post name so we i
don't i mean if you want you can include
the dates in here if you want to include
the day and name or the month and name
or a number but we're just going to have
the name of the post after the the root
url but it's really up to you how you
want to do that so i'll just go to save
changes and we're done with that
next we'll update the theme the theme is
the overall look and feel of a website
certain themes will make it easier to
update different parts of the website so
let me go to appearance and
themes
so by default there's just these three
themes and we're on this one right now
but there's hundreds or thousands of
wordpress themes you can install and
we're going to do that right now we're
going to install just one of the one new
one so i'm going to click on add new
theme
and like i said each theme
is going to make it easier to update
different parts of the website so
there's tons of different options here
but what we're going to do is install
one that's very popular and also
allows a lot of customization this is
called ocean wp so i'm going to search
for ocean wp
if i click on here
details and preview we can see that this
has 5 stars it has 4 559 ratings and
this one has is one of the more popular
wordpress themes and one of the reasons
why is because it's so customizable it
also can work with woocommerce just in
case you want an e-commerce store but to
install this theme i'm just going to go
to install up here
and this is going to give us a lot of
options no matter what type of website
we're trying to create
it's one of the more popular free
wordpress themes
it's especially good for beginners it
includes high quality pre-made designs
and it's very easy to customize okay
it's installed and now i'm going to
click activate okay and you can see
right here new theme activated visit
site so let's visit site and this is
what let me refresh here
okay so this is now what our website
looks like with our new theme
it still doesn't it still doesn't look
very nice because we're still going
going to be doing a lot more updating to
customizing exactly how we want but this
theme is going to make customizing even
easier and you can see now you can see
this bar at the top
this bar is going to appear anytime
you're logged in to wordpress and you're
on your website and it's going to make
it easier to customize individual pages
if i just click customize here i could
start start editing this page directly
we're not going to do that right now but
we will do that a little later i'm going
to go back to the dashboard so i'm going
to click right here
and now we're going to add some plugins
that we need so i'm going to go to
plugins
so a theme determines the look and feel
of your website plugins add new features
and functionalities
for instance with a plugin you can add a
contact form to your website also you
could block spam comments implement a
shopping cart there's just tons of
different things that plugins can help
you add to your website depending on
what theme there may be some recommended
plugins and one of them is ocean extra
for this one so let's just begin
installing this plugin and then i'll
click install
okay now after we get ocean xr installed
there's just one more plugin we're going
to install go to add new and this next
one is called elementor
and you can see this has 5 million
active installations it's one of the
most popular wordpress
plugins and
it makes it very easy to design
professional looking web pages without
coding it gives a drag and drop
page builder you can see pixel perfect
design mobile responsive editing it
makes it just a lot easier especially
for beginners to design a website so i'm
going to install this one
okay let's go to the list of all of our
plugins again i'm going to select them
all
and then i'm going to activate
apply
so we're going to activate both plugins
that we installed so here's this welcome
screen we're going to just skip this we
don't need to go through this getting
started right now
and let's go back to the plugins again
just to make sure it worked
the elementor is activated but we need
to make sure ocean extra is also
activated
you know i think this plugin got
installed wrong so that could happen if
that happens no it's not a problem we'll
just delete this and then we're going to
reinstall it
so let me just refresh this page
and begin installing this program again
this plug-in i mean
i think the problem is i went off the
page while i was installing it before so
that could happen to you too not a
problem just delete it and then
reinstall it
okay it's all installed it could take a
little while you just have to kind of
wait till it finishes so i'll go to
return to dashboard
and with
oceanwt it has a setup wizard so let's
do run the setup wizard
and it's going to show you the different
things that you can do so to get started
so the first thing to do is select the
demo template so this is something
that's pretty great about oceanwp is
that it has all these demos included
with it and
a lot of them are free now the way they
make money is that some of them you do
have to pay for but these ones that are
included here these are ones are all
free that we can see right here so we
can choose which demo looks most similar
to what we want if you're going to do an
e-commerce you can do store we have
personal simple
you can even do a preview so i could do
a live preview of this
and then
see and if i like this preview i can
import it you can see there's different
uh
blog tips so we're gonna go to with
something more simple here i'm just
gonna go back here
okay and i kind of like the this lawyer
one now you can create you can choose
any one you want and all the things i'm
about to teach you are going to apply no
matter which of these
demo templates that you choose
and i'm not making a page about a lawyer
but i just like some of these things
that are in the lawyer page i kind of
like how it's set up and like i said
we're going to be able to change every
single one of the we're going to be able
to customize this so you don't have to
be making
a website about whatever the like the
name of this
demo is
we can choose lawyer even though we're
not making a website about a lawyer so
i'll just select this one
and i'll go to the bottom and install
demo
and depending on which demo you install
there's going to be specific plugins
that are necessary just for that demo so
let's click install now
install now
now when it says get this add-on that
means we are going to actually have to
pay extra for it
but the good thing is it's optional
we don't need to get this add-on it's
just an optional thing that you can get
and so we're just not even going to get
those add-ons and we're going to see how
we can still customize and make the
website exactly how we want even without
getting those add-ons so i will now
click import
and here is where we we can customize it
right from the screen if we wanted we
can upload a new logo we can set the
title the tagline and the thing is we
can actually change all this stuff later
so i'm going to skip this step because i
want to show you how we can change all
this stuff right from within wordpress
so i'm going to skip this step
and you know we don't need any of this
stuff so i'll just click view the
website
okay so now i'm going to click visit
website
and so here is our updated website you
can see it's all about being a lawyer
now but we can change all of that and we
are going to do that so i'm going to
close this okay we're back at the
dashboard let me dismiss this
we can also if we want to we can
activate this
but i don't want to so i'm going to skip
it and going to this theme panel button
here if somehow you messed up when you
were installing your demo or it didn't
install right or you went off the screen
you could go and click on this theme
panel and this is where you would
install the demo you could run the setup
wizard which we already ran we could run
that again but we're not going to run
that again we already ran it okay we got
our theme and our demo installed let's
just see what it looks like i can go up
here click visit site
and so this is our lawyer theme
like obviously like i said we're not
lawyers but the next step i'm going to
show you is how to use this as the base
of our website and just go through and
start customizing things and how to
customize the text how to customize the
image how to customize layouts to go
along with what our site is actually
supposed to be about
so i'm going to go back over to the
dashboard
we decided we're not going to activate
these social sharing buttons so let me
show you how to remove this message
uh it just got installed with everything
else so i can
click here and go just to i can just
deactivate it's a temporary dfx
deactivation because who knows maybe
we'll want it in the future
okay i'm going to go back over here
and that gives gets that out of the way
now we're going to install just one more
plug-in before we start customizing
everything so i'm going to go back to
the plug-ins screen again i guess it
could have stayed on there
and the plugin is going to help us back
up our wordpress site it's good to have
everything backed up just in case you
make a mistake or something goes wrong
you want to have a backup of your
website so you can use it later and also
let's just get rid of this too because
this is a paid extension which we don't
really need so i'll just get rid of that
it's basically just an ad that shows up
so
i'm going to go to add new and this time
we're going to install a plug-in that
will help us back up our
wordpress installation and this one is
going to be called all
and
so we get all in one wp
migration and this is going to allow us
to back up our site and you can see it's
very popular three three million
installations
and we're just getting that installed
okay that's installed i'm going to
activate that
okay now let me show you how that this
would work you click on
all in one wp migration and we can
export there's two ways to do the backup
one we can export our entire site to
store on our computer so if we just do
export to file
okay now just click download
you can close that
and then you can always just import it
if you want to
another way is to go to the backups tab
here
so
the cool thing about this extension is
it will also automatically save backups
right to your wordpress server so you
don't actually even need to download
anything it's good to export the site
every once in a while so you have a back
like a master backup
but you can also create a backup right
onto the wordpress server and it will
just be saved right onto your server and
then whenever you want you can either
download it or you can restore right
from here so that's another way to do
backups
and now we're going to start customizing
the website
so we could go right through these links
here to customize another way you could
customize is going to the theme panel
and then at the very bottom there's all
these things about uploading your logo
adding the favicon choosing your primary
color choosing your typography so you
could update it through that way but i'm
going to show you a different way to
update it the way the reason why this
other update way to update is good
because it works across all themes
even if you don't even install a custom
theme you can still update your website
this way so i'm going to go to
the dashboard actually i'm going to go
right to the site here and click visit
site and once you're on the site you can
go to any page in your site
and you can just click
customize
so now we're customizing anything and we
can click on any of these
sections here to customize different
things
so first we're going to customize the
general look of everything so i'm going
to go to site identity
and we already know the title is robot
family reviews which you could change if
you wanted
for the tagline and this could show up
in search bars or i mean in search
engine so it's good to have something
that really relates your your website
here so i'm going to say
reviews of robot
toys
and then i'll go back now i'm going to
make a lot of changes and then i'm going
to click publish to publish all of them
at once
so or i can actually just publish it
right now and then you can kind of we'll
see how it go the changes as we go
so now i'm going to change the logo we
got the logo here i'll just click this
logo and you can also go
a different way to do it you can click
header
and then we can click logo to update the
logo and i'm going to remove this logo
we are going to create well you can see
removing the logo automatically just
puts text here instead of the logo so
i'm going to create an all new logo to
use on this website
so there's a cool website you can use to
create a logo for free okay i'm at
logomaker.com and we're going to create
our logo so i'm going to do a search and
remember this is all about robots so you
can search for anything but i'm going to
search for the word robot
[Music]
and try to see which thing i want to use
for my
logo
uh a lot of these look kind of cool i
kind of like the simplicity of this one
so i'm going to use this as my logo
and then i'm going to put some text here
too and it's just going to be called
robot
reviews
and so i will make this a little bigger
i can move this around
and
i had zoomed in a
little bit but i will zoom out
okay so i'll click this text and this is
where you can change the font
so let's see which one looks the most
like a robot
well i kind of like this one i guess
it's not like a robot but we're gonna
change the colors of everything too i
can select both of these and now i can
make this color go to any type of color
i want
i'm going to do this
blue color
kind of like this
and i'm going to make this text a little
bigger so it's closer to the size of
of this image
and then i'll make the image a little
smaller
okay robot reviews so now i'm going to
click the save button
i don't need the high resolution i'm
just going to say no thanks download the
low resolution and the great thing about
this website is it's one of the few
websites where you don't have to create
an account in order to create a free
logo
so we got that
now i just want one with just this robot
thing so i'm going to click the text i'm
going to delete the text now i'm going
to save that
and i'll download the low resolution
file
okay let's go back to our wordpress site
and now i'm going to select the logo
okay i'm just going to drag this over
from off screen
so
then
i'm going to
call it robot reviews
logo
and i'll put that as the alt text also
and then click select
and then i'm gonna make sure the whole
thing is selected up here
and
crop image or you can just do skip
cropping
okay now if i hit publish it should show
up on here
and then i'm also going to have to
refresh the page
okay if you add the logo and it doesn't
show up correctly
it could be because if you're on a
retina display
it still has the other
default logo stored as the retina logo
so you may have to go in here you may
have to select an image
and if you just choose an image and it
could get really small but then if you
just remove
then it will default to the normal logo
whether you have the retina display or
not so that's something i ran into since
i do have a retina display that i'm
recording this on you may just have to
select any logo and then remove it and
then it'll just default back to the
normal logo
okay so we have the logo updated
so now let's see how we can update the
general colors used on our website you
can see how it uses this gold color
there's a line right here there's a gold
color there's a line right here
so let's see how we can update what
colors are used on the website i go back
here
okay i'm going to go to general options
i'm going to general styling
and now we can select what our primary
and hover colors are and the border
color we can update all these different
colors so i want to figure out what
color this robot reviews
logo is so let me go back over to my
logo website and i can actually just
copy this hex color right here i can see
this number right here with letters this
is the the color
so i'm going to just copy that and i'll
go back over to wordpress and now i'm
gonna
put that as the primary color so i can
go around and select any color like this
or i can just paste in a hex code
and
then we're done with that and then for
my
hover my hover primary color i'm just
going to choose something that's a
little darker
maybe a little purplish here and now i'm
going to click publish
and then i'll refresh
and you can see a few things change
colors so we have these down here that
change colors this little line but we
have to ch we have to update the color
in a few more places i'll show you that
later
but now let's add the favicon so we
update the logo we updated some colors
and we'll be doing more colors later and
now let's update the favicon which is
what appears in a tab or the you in the
bar in your browser like in the tab
right next to the site name that little
picture so we're gonna go to
site identity
and then select a site icon so i'm just
gonna upload a file here
and then i'm going to upload this so
i'll put favicon
and then i'll just select that
and it shows a preview of what it's
going to look like
looks pretty good
okay i'll crop the image
now there's a bunch more things we can
customize you can see there's all these
things we can customize and we're gonna
come back to a few of these later
if you want you can play around yourself
and just try changing things you can
always go back if you
make try something one way you can
always go back to the other way you can
kind of experiment with what your
website you with what you want your
website to look like
but i'm going to show you another way to
be editing the website and that's what
we're going to use to edit some of these
colors and some other things so we're
going to do something to edit the actual
content of the website so this is mainly
editing what things look like like the
logo some colors
fonts font size
but we're going to edit actually the
text and then other things on the
website so let me click publish to make
sure everything's published here hit x
here
okay now we're going to go through and
find out how to edit each section of
this
website we are going to find out how to
change the words change more colors
change the layout add images
add links and it's all possibly simpler
than you would expect
so you'll notice that we no longer have
the top bar in here it's because i
actually restarted my browser and it got
logged out
so
whenever you don't see the top bar that
means you're logged out of wordpress
and you need to get logged back in
before you can start editing so let's do
that again so if you remember you just
go to the main url and do wp slash admin
and then you go to that page you can log
in with the information you you set up
when you first installed wordpress
[Music]
okay now i can go back to the site by
going to visit site and then anytime you
see this top bar you on each page you
can either click edit page or edit with
elementor now edit page is the default
way of editing it's called gutenberg and
it's pretty good but
there's elementor just makes it more
user friendly there's a lot it's more
graphical you can drag things around and
it kind of gives you a little more
it makes a little some things a little
easier to do so we're going to go to
edit with elementor
okay so here's elementor we have our
page on this side but we have this new
menu over here which are elements we can
add to the page so we can actually bring
in elements just like i can click an
element like image and i can bring it
right here and it will put an image here
now it's currently blank or a
placeholder image but i'll show you how
to actually make into your own image in
a second here but you can also click on
any of these spots
and edit
the sections now see i have to actually
scroll back and forth that's just
because i'm kind of zoomed in here so
you can see the elements on the page a
little better
on your computer
it may actually just show up everything
at once you may not have to scroll back
and forth here
so here you can actually just edit the
text so i can say
read
amazing
robot reviews
okay over here we can change settings
like i can center the text i can write a
line
i can go to style i can change the the
text color if i wanted see i can make it
any color
i'm just going to keep it as white but i
can even change the blend mode so maybe
if i do lighten
see how this what this looks so if i go
to overlay you can kind of see it now
you can see through it just slightly
i can turn on a text shadow
if i want so i could
so i could make this darker
so you can do all sorts of things
now this text is not going to let me
change the size here
because there's some text where where
it's
like key
pieces of content the styling is
actually in a different spot but if i go
down here i should be able to change the
size so
if i go
over here now this is just
basically default text um
placeholder text i'm going to keep the
placeholder text i'm not going to go
through and add updated text for every
section but if you're creating your own
website obviously every piece of
placeholder text you're going to want to
update to the content that you actually
want
but you can change things like if i
select that i can make that bold and you
can see it changes the bold over here
see i can scroll down here and there's
more settings i can change
so
i could change the columns
so now there's 10 columns of text but
we'll just go to default because we
really just want a single column there
and so you can just go through and
change all these things so we also have
the style here so let's see if we can
change the style so we can change the
text color the typography
if i choose typography i can actually
change the size of the text so here
i can basically make it as large or
small
as i want
but i'm just going to delete if you just
delete the number together is it'll just
go to
to kind of the default size i already
was but if you want a different size
that's where you would change in here
so there's just a bunch of different
settings you can change to get the style
exactly right for for what you're
looking for
and there's even some advanced settings
so if you change the margin that's going
to change the how much space is is above
the text or below the text so if i
change this if i
make it so that values aren't linked
together and make this go up you can see
how there's it's getting more space on
the right of the text can bring that
back to zero
and if i do bottom i can put like 70
here you can see it's putting more space
on the bottom of the text but i'm just
going to keep this at zero and there's
all these things different things you
can change like you can even add motion
effects
so this would actually add an animation
to the text so if i do fade in you can
see it gives an example of it fading in
or you can make it moving
going from the left right there
so there's a lot of different cool
things you can do
to make it just unique and specific to
what you're trying to do for your
website
and so let's say i want to change this
here so contact our attorneys
so if i click here
you can see this is where it's linking
to anytime you see this pound sign or
this hashtag here that just means it's a
placeholder link there it's not actually
linking to anything but really we want
it so there's two things we can make
this link to we could either link this
to an email address but we're going to
link it to our contact page so our
contact page i can actually go here
right click
and go to copy link address and if i
paste this in here we can see it's
robotfamilyreviews.com
contact so now when someone clicks here
we'll go to the contact page
but let's also change what the text
looks like so instead of contact our
attorneys i'm going to make it contact
our
reviewers
[Music]
okay so now when someone clicks that it
will go to the contact page and now
let's see how we can change these
different elements you can change some
colors on the page by changing the
overall styles on the page like i showed
you earlier but some elements are
colored individually so i can click on
here and then go to style
and then here i'm going to get the hex
value that we're using on the other
parts of the page that blue make it here
so i'm just going to paste that that hex
value in from that we were using before
and you can see it's changing to this
blue here and you can do that for any
element so like i can click on this
this icon here
and i can go to style and now i'm going
to show you an even easier way to do it
so yes we can select the color
individually but this time we're going
to use the global colors so let me show
you how we're going to set the global
colors i'm going to manage global colors
so so we have the colors through
elementor and then we have the colors on
wordpress so we already set the colors
on wordpress now i'm going to set the
global colors on elementor
and i'm just going to paste in the hex
value again
so now we have this blue
and for now we'll just leave these the
same so let's go back here
if i go here i'm going to save save the
global colors
if i click on here then i can set it as
the primary color here
so i can do it for all these things i
don't know why this icon wasn't showing
up but i knew it was there so i just
click there and i can set this there
again click on this icon which for some
reason wasn't showing up
and i can go through each
icon here and change it to the color
the blue color we're going to use and
then so here's another element here this
little line right there click there
and this time we have to go to this
border section because it's actually
just a border on one side
and i can change that to the primary
color
okay so
let me show you how to add a picture i
added this placeholder picture
and what you're going to want to do
unless you have a lot of your own
photography for different products
we can go and get some royalty free
photos that we can use right on our
website
there are some few a few extensions some
a few wordpress
extensions that you can
uh install that will make this simpler
to do right from wordpress but you can
also just go to the royalty free
websites yourself so one popular one is
pexels.com so i'm just going to search
i'm at pexels.com i'm going to search
for a robot
okay so look at all these robot pictures
all these are royalty free that anybody
can use so let's see which one i want to
use i kind of like
how about this one okay i'm going to
download it but instead of just
downloading the
original it's a little bigger than what
we need so i'm going to go to the the
medium size
if it's too big it'll just take too long
to load so i'm going to click free
download
and now i'll go back over to elementor
we'll go to choose image upload files
and then i can just drag it right into
here
okay all text and just you know alt text
is what displays when people are using
screen readers so some people may be
accessing your website that can't see
the image but they can use a screen
reader to have it read out what the
image is of so it's always important to
include alt text so i'll put robot
staring
at
camera
or maybe at you
okay so insert media
and now we have a robot here
so now let's see how we can update see
we have this background image right here
that we have this lady staring here so
to update the background image we're
going to have to update this whole
section so i'm going to click right here
and now that click here i have the
editing for this box so you can see this
blue line now surrounding this whole
section
and now we can change things about this
so what i'm going to go i'm going to go
to style now we have this image now i
want to change this and use a different
image so here's another cool website for
finding free royalty free images which
is
unsplash.com so let me try searching for
robots here
okay so this now we have a whole new set
of images we can deal with now i kind of
like this one this is cool for a
background image so i'm going to click
here go to download i'm going to do
download
medium
okay now i'm going to do choose image
i'm going to upload a file and then i'm
just going to bring in this image again
and since it's just a background image
we don't need alt text so insert that
media
so now we have a new image in the
background so that's pretty
cool i'm kind of looking at this i
notice that there's a lot of space above
the text there's a lot of space below
the text
that's too much space that's easy to
switch so i'm still i'm already on the
editing for this section because i click
this
six dot thing here and i'll go to layout
so i'm on the layout tab
and minimum height so if i make this
height go down
now there's going to be less space above
and below i'm changing what the height
of this section is so that kind of that
looks
a little better to me so we can get to
the next section
and let's change from this text so
instead of practice areas we'll do our
focus
and then we're going to change these
different sections instead of family law
we'll do stem
[Music]
programming
toys
and fun
and then we can try to find
not fun law then we can try to find an
icon that goes along with each one and
it makes it easy to change the icon so
if i just click on this icon here
and i go to content
i can go to icon library
okay for stem i will use a school icon
for programming let's see if we can
change this to maybe a computer
laptop with a little code icon
and then for toys
content
for toys i'm just going to scroll down
and see oh paper airplane like that for
a toy
and then for fun we'll just do a grin
here
okay now you may want to get rid of
sections so like this section that
doesn't really apply to us so we can
actually just press x and get rid of
this
teams
no
this is something maybe we want so
we could change this to review team
and then you could go through and change
i'm not going to update all these names
but you would
you could update the pictures you can up
choose the image to get pictures of
different teammates and then we may want
to change this text so go to style
and then for color
primary color and then we just go
through each one and change the style to
make sure it's all the color that we
want
basically you just want to go through
these menus till you find the thing that
find the setting that will change what
you want to change
and the great thing is pretty much
everything can be changed
now you can see i don't know why these
weren't showing up but these are social
media
icons so let's say you want to
get this the social media links for the
every person on your team so you go in
here and you would just click right on
here
and then you would put the twitter like
https
colon slash less
twitter
dot com slash bow carns
and then you would do that and put the
link for each
each social media link for each person
on your team you can also add new social
media links so maybe do add item
and you go to the icon library maybe you
want to add a github link so we get that
icon insert
and now we have another link and then
you would put the link right here you
just type in the link okay so let's keep
going down here
um
this one we're just going to delete that
section because we don't need that
section here is another thing that we
could change
so like we could change this we could
easily change the colors so styles we
can do
primary color
and then now when you hover it still
doesn't it doesn't stay blue so you're
going to choose colors two times so in
the normal mode and the hover mode so
that's why you have to look for these
settings to make sure you change the
color in every place the color needs to
be changed so we can go through and do
these on these other ones too
and again you can go through and update
this text you can update this text you
can change the text you can update this
link
again it's
so this one you may want to use your
contact link again
so we could update this to slash contact
and then we can update the background
image so just like before to upgrade the
background image we're going to click
here
and then we can go to style
and then we could choose the image we
can
update the image to a different image
let me show you how you would have your
own section like let's say this section
is no not not like what we want i can
get rid of that section
we can get rid of this section but what
if i want to add a whole new section in
between here
so what you want to do if you want to
add a section is just click this plus
button
and now it's going to have an empty
thing right here so i'm going to bring
over an inner section
so this intersection now has two tabs
here or two columns i mean
so we can add something different each
of these columns so hit plus here
let's say we want to add a video on this
side
and let's say we want to add
an image
on this side
so let me show you how you would update
what it what the video is so let me
scroll over here so i have to you have
to click this little edit button on the
top of the corner at the video
and so i can update this video so i'm
gonna or we can update this link i'm
just gonna paste in and now we have a
different video we have the video we
want to be featured here
and then you can also do something like
start time end time you can change a
different source if you want the the
video to be
from some different location you can
change autoplay there's all these
different settings you can change here
you probably want to turn on
privacy mode so youtube won't store
information about visitors on your
website unless they play the video so
that's just a
nice thing to do for your visitors
and then then with images we can change
the image just like before so we're
going to change the image
we click on image we can go to content
and then we can choose the image so we
can choose an image that's already on
there this time i'm just gonna make it
simple i'm just going to
add an image that we already have so how
about this one
okay and then we can even change the
background of this whole section so if i
click
here
now let's say i instead of white in the
background i want a different color so i
can go to style
and then background overlay or not
background overlay i want to go to
background
and then you can change the different so
classic gradient video or slideshow so
you can actually have a video playing in
the background and you can get that
video directly from youtube
i'm gonna do a gradient this time so
the first color we're gonna take a blue
and then the second color we're going to
have like a lighter blue here
i guess it's like a black to turquoise
and now you can see there's a gradient
in the background
and i'm going to actually change the you
can change the
the angle i'm just gonna do a 90 degree
angle
and it doesn't really look that good but
i'm just trying to show off the
different things you can do
so let's delete this whole section here
and let's say you want your your map you
want to have a map of where you're
located at so let me show you how you
would change where it shows where it
shows in the map
so i'm going to go to this section
and actually you may have to hit this
edit button right up here
and right now the location is new york
well let's try michigan
that's the state i live in and
we'll zoom out a little bit
you could also put a city or you could
even put a
very specific address if you wanted to
but for now we'll just say michigan
and let's just keep going down here so
this is like an empty section of the
page
but
this only shows up when you're editing
when you're on your page it's not going
to show here
so let's just look at what our page
looks like so far so i'm going to click
update and then preview changes
okay so this is what our page looks like
so far it looks a little different and
you can go through and see oh there's a
few things i
uh i didn't change the color of so let's
go do that now that's it's you're good
to preview every few seconds so you can
er every few minutes to see if there's
anything you still need to do so i want
to change that color so let me just go
to edit with elementor
i'm going to change this section
sometimes there'll be colors in various
places so you kind of have to click
around to find out the exact spot but
for this one it was border
and we can change the color here scroll
down
there's one go to border
at this point you probably know exactly
how to change this
this stuff here
style
and to change the color of the text on
these buttons
is going to require some custom css
it's not too difficult but i'm going to
save this to show you for later
so we're basically done updating this
main page
oh lawyer firm how about
robot firm
and we'll preview changes
okay now let me show you how you would
update a few different types of sections
first i'm going to show you how to
delete add and delete sections to this
menu here
and then how to
make some changes to the news or blog
section so this news is also similar to
a blog so a lot of
websites are going to have a new section
or a blog section that's kind of a
different type of section than the other
sections so first let's go through and
find out how to add and remove sections
so right so first of all let's say you
wanted to edit this section if you want
to edit just like before you do edit
with elementor
and then you would use all the same
types of editing that we saw before you
can edit here you can add a new section
you can delete a section or edit the
whole section just like this before but
really what we want to do is completely
remove this section so let me show you
how you would do that if there's a whole
page in your website that you don't even
want how would you remove that
so first of all you would see which
sections you want to remove well
we don't want any of these three
sections so i'm going to remove all the
three of these sections and then i'm
going to show you how to add an all new
section so these are the type of things
that you may want to do when you're
developing your own website you want to
know how to remove a page and how to add
completely new pages so let me show you
that to remove this you're not going to
do it from the edit with elementor to
the edit page we're going to have to go
back to our dashboard
just so you know there's two types of
basically pages we have normal pages and
then we have posts so posts are like our
blog posts and you can see these are all
some sample posts that they put in there
and then we also have pages which is our
different pages like we have the blog
page
we which is i think the news page
contacts fact home
practice areas so we are going to do a
few things first of all
we want to
we're just going to remove some of these
sections we don't need the attorneys
page
we don't we're going to keep the
contacts page we don't need the f the
fact page practice areas and we're just
going to delete those three pages
so
i'm going to bulk actions and move to
trash
and then apply
and click no thanks here
okay now let's see what our page looks
like now that those have been removed
i'm going to visit site
and you can see now they're not even
showing up in here
so
let's see how we can now add a new page
also i'll show you how you would remove
a section from this menu even though you
don't want to delete that that page from
your website so i'll show you that first
and then i'll show you how to add new
ones so let's say we want to remove the
news section from this menu here i'm
going to go back
well let me close on these extra tabs
here i'm going to go back to our
dashboard
and
let's change
the menu
so let me go to appearance and then
menus
so these are how we're going to change
the menus so i want to change the main
menu and not the footer menu so i'll
select that
and so
we're going to want to delete well it
still has the element the page that we
deleted so if you delete the page you
also want to delete it off the menu so
i'm going to do is click here
remove
click here
remove
click here
remove
and the same way that's how you would
remove the news page so i could click
here and remove now that didn't remove
that page from our website it's just
removed it from the menu so if i click
save menu
and then if i go to the site we don't
have the news but if i go to the url and
do slash news
well i guess that's not what it was
called i think was called blog
okay so we can still see it so here is
the blog it's still on here even though
we removed it from the menu so let's see
how to add it back to the menu go back
to the dashboard we're gonna go right
back to where we were appearance
and menus
and then
i'm going to add an item here so let's
do view all i'm gonna
select the blog
and i'm going to add to the menu now
this is going to be different now
because it says blog before it said news
so let's see how we can call it news
instead of calling it blog we're going
to call it news so this is going to
change what it says right in the menu
item but actually we don't want it to be
called news or blog we want it to be
called reviews because these are going
to be our robot reviews so i'm going to
save the menu like that and if we go
back to the page i'll actually open up
into a new tab this time and then we can
see home reviews contact us so that's
how you add or remove sections from this
menu so now i want to show you how you
would add an all new page
okay so to create a
new page we can just click add new and
then we have the add new button here too
so we're on the page section we're gonna
click add new
and we're gonna just give this a title
for this example we're gonna do
programming lessons so people who are
really into robots can learn how to
program robots
how we're going to edit this after we
get the title here we're going to go to
this template instead of the default
template we're going to do uh elementor
full width you can kind of experiment
with different things
but the elementor full width will allow
us to have a page without anything
without any sidebars or anything and
that's we're going to do for this
example
so i'm going to click edit with
elementor
okay now we're editing the page and you
can see that it still has our normal
header and our normal fitter footer
but we just need to add what's going to
be in here and you can see it's going to
have some breadcrumbs here with the home
and the programming lessons
and now we can just add sections here so
if i click plus then we can just
choose how many columns we're going to
have
and then you can add elements into each
one of those columns like you could put
pictures in one column text in another
buttons in another video in another
maybe a map or or maybe two columns of
text it's really up to you what you want
to add to each column i'm just gonna go
with the two column layout again here
and so you can see uh we can also change
the size of the columns so right now we
have a small column on this side and
then a larger column on the other side
and it's always going to have this drag
widget here just in case you want to add
something to the bottom of the page
but when we we actually preview the page
when we see what it actually looks like
it's not going to have this thing down
here so let's add something to the
column so i'm going to do is put an
image on this side and some text on this
side and on this side i'm going to show
you how you can have columns inside of a
column so here we're going to add an
image i'm going to go back to unsplash
and put robots
and i'm going to grab this one the rock
and roll monkey robot so i'm going to
download and instead of downloading the
largest one i'm going to go to the
medium one
and then we'll go back over here
i'm gonna choose image upload files i'm
just going to drag this over
and then for the alt text i will put
monkey robot kind of i guess not really
a monkey it's
looks some kind somewhat similar to a
monkey
but it was called rock and roll monkey
so
what i'm going to do
is now
put some text here so first
i'm going to put this text editor here
and we're going to say
if you
want programming
lessons
if you want
robot programming lessons
[Music]
you come
to the right spot
[Music]
here is what we offer and now i'm going
to add another section down here so i'm
going to
go to insert section
okay so now we have two columns inside
this column
so on this i'm going to add a heading
and the heading is going to be
scratch
programming
and then
over here we'll have a heading
which will be
python programming
and then we can just add more text in
here so let's keep going back here to
until we can insert a the text editor
we're going to enter insert a text
editor on both sides here
and so here's where we would talk about
the scratch program here's when we talk
about the python programming and another
thing you can cool thing you can do is
if i click here
i can go to duplicate
and now actually i have three columns i
just duplicated this column so we can do
another type of programming
maybe we can do
javascript programming
and then i can
go back over here we're going to add a
button
the button is going to be right at the
bottom here
and i'm going to change this instead of
click here it's going to say
contact us for details
so it's basically a call to action
and then for that link
i'm going to go right to the contact
page which we are going to be developing
pretty soon here
okay now let me publish this
i'm going to have a look
okay so programming lessons
and you can see we have two sections
here
and then it goes right to our footer
down here so using this method you can
add as many pages you want to your web
page now we also want to make sure it's
up here so let's add our programming
lessons to our navigation
so i'll go
to our dashboard
and then appearance
menus
and then we're on our main menu so we're
going to add programming lessons add to
menu now we can drag this up it's going
to be called home
programming lessons reviews contact us
and you can also have sub menus by
this becomes a sub menu if i pull over
but we want it all on the root level so
i'll save the menu and then let's visit
the site
okay so here's the home page
and obviously we still have to would
have to kind of update some of this text
i'm not going to go through and update
all the text but you can't get the idea
of how to update all this text here
and if we go to programming lessons
so here's that
and all looks good
now the next two things we're going to
do we're going to update this reviews
page or the blog page we're going to
update the contact page
and then after that
yeah this isn't working at all after
that we're going to update the footer
let's go to the reviews page here so
first of all some people that make a
website they want to only be a blog they
may want this blog page with their
different posts like this to appear
as their homepage when someone first
goes to their website so let me show you
how to do that we'll go to the dashboard
okay so how to make the blog as your
main page we're going to go to settings
and then reading
and then we would set the home page as
your latest post so let me just show you
what that would look like if we set that
as your uac post i'll go here go to the
page again
okay now if we go to our url up here
we're at the root url there's no slash
or anything after it and you can see
it's the blog posts
but let's turn that back so we'll go
again we'll go to
settings
reading
and then we'll do static page
now we're going to set this again so our
main page our homepage is going to be
home and our post page is going to be
blog and here's how you can actually
change a little bit what your blog your
your blog page is going to look like so
you can check choose how many blogs are
going to show up on each page
you can
show freeze posts in the feed is it
going to be the full text or summary
uh if you want to discourage search
engines from indexing the site
usually you're going to want this off
because most people want it to appear in
search engines but if for some reason
you don't you can click that so let's
save changes and now let's see how we
can update our blog page
so the blog page is a special type of
page that the way you change the layout
it's a little different than the other
pages so we're going to go to appearance
and then customize
then we'll go to blog
and then the blog entries
so we're going to change what the blog
entries page looks like and there
actually is a different way to do that
if we didn't have this up and let's say
we are on our site if we go to reviews
and then we can just click customize
here
and then it should open that up that
screen up where we were just at
okay and then we'll still have to go to
blog
blog entries
and this is where we can change what
this is going to look like
so right now we have it with the right
sidebar you can't really see it now i'm
actually going to change the zoom level
on chrome here
okay so now you can see the sidebar here
and this is where we're going to
actually edit you can edit those
different sections so right now we're
not using elementor at all we're using
the default wordpress editor to edit
this blog page you can't edit this
section with elementor
so here is where we can
make any edits we want so one thing we
can do is go to left sidebar and it just
switches the sidebar to the other side
but let's keep right right sidebar and
then it says this is mobile sidebar
order that means if you're on a mobile
device there's these buttons down here
so you can switch to different types of
view this is like a tablet view
this is like a mobile view here so
if we change this
so now it's going to show the sidebar
first and then it's going to show the
content or we want to show the content
first and then the sidebar because on a
mobile device you're not going to be
able to show both the content and the
sidebar at the same time so it's going
to put one after the other so that's
what this is all about
and this would change the size of these
headings but it doesn't work for this
particular theme that we're using
let's go back to desktop view
but you can also change the style so
large image okay we can also do grid
or we can do thumbnail
so it's up to you what you want your
main page to look like i actually kind
of like this i like thumbnail and then
you can change where's the image is it
going to be a right or left
you can change the vertical position
so you can see there's a lot of
different settings you can change on
here
pagination style so we have the pages
down here so we could change it to
infinite scroll so just keep
uh loading more and more blog posts
until you get to the end of content
which is i guess we're at the end of
content now so let's go back to
standard we can also delete anything
over here that we don't want so for
instance i don't want this calendar i'll
just click here
and then i can go to remove
and then we're not going to hook up with
instagram so i can remove that
but if you wanted to you could just go
into the settings in there
we'll keep the recent comments recent
post and
actually we have this
twice here i don't know if we need all
this so let's just make sure we only
have everything one time so right now
you have somehow got the recent post
recent comments recent posters and
comments that's a little too many so
i can just remove that
we can remove this
and then if we edit this recent post you
can still change things like instead of
doing uh three posts let's show the five
most recent posts and there's a bunch of
other settings you can change to make
this look exactly like you want
but this looks pretty good
so the next thing i want to show you is
how someone can
how you can load create new blog posts
so
let's publish this
so to make new blog posts there's two
ways if you're in this screen right here
you can just click new and then suddenly
you're creating a new blog post just
like that
and if you're already over here you can
click add new here
and i'm going to minimize this because
we don't want to be looking at these
settings all the time you can go into
those settings to customize exactly
again what everything looks like
but we don't need to be looking at those
settings
so uh we're going to be reviewing
different robots so let's say we're
going to review the cosmo robot
this is a great robot
and just like before now we we could
edit with elementor but personally i
think for blog post it's good to i would
just recommend using the default editor
just to make everything look consistent
you want all the blog posts to look
very consistent between the different
blog posts and using the built-in editor
instead of elementor is one way to make
things uh look consistent and the
built-in editor is great for just doing
text or just doing blog posts where
elementor is good for like moving around
different things on the page so we're
gonna use just this built-in editor but
just like and with elementor you can
still add a bunch of stuff like i can
click this plus button here
i can add a form i can add an image
heading a gallery so i'm going to add a
gallery so in a gallery i can actually
pick a lot of different images so let's
say just we could
upload more images but i'm just going to
select these to show as an example
and i'll do insert gallery so you could
potentially like have a bunch of images
of cosmo robot
and then you would show this in a
gallery you can also insert a single
image there's a bunch of different
things you can insert
and you can do browse all so you can
actually these are all the different
things you can put a quote you can put a
table
you can put a verse
like poetry with special format a quote
so there's a bunch of different types of
things that you can enter insert right
into your post so let's say i'm done i'm
going to click publish and publish
okay now i'll view the post
okay here's my blog post so
it says cosmo robot review this is the
great robot and then you can see this
gallery here and then people can leave a
comment here now if i go to um now if i
go to reviews it shows up as the first
review but i noticed a few things one
there's no image like these other ones
and it's uncategorized usually you'll
have
a group that this is under so let's go
back to
the post i'll go in here and then i can
just go to edit post
okay i'm going to go to categories and
then i'm going to add a new category
this category is going to be called
review reviews
and then add new category and now it's
going to be under reviews instead of
uncategorized so the default is
uncategorized but we may want to be
called reviews
so
now and you basically can add as many
categories as you want and you can
put each blog post into whatever
categories you want you can also use
tags but we're going to use the feature
featured image okay i'll go to set
featured image and make sure you're on
upload files and then i'll drag this in
here
and this actually is a picture of
cosmo
i'll put cosmo front because it's the
front of them set featured image
okay i will update this
and then i'm gonna go down here view
post
okay cosmo robot review and it's under
reviews this is a great post
and then people can leave replies here
and then if i go to
reviews
we can see
that it appears at the top of this list
here
okay let's go into this review let's say
you want to change the format like what
your blog post displays like we can go
to customize here
i go to blog and then single post
and you can adjust things like for
instance i can
decide whether the feature image is
before after the title maybe i want to
move the title above the feature image
okay so now it says cosmo robot review
and then we have an image
i kind of liked it how how it was
and you can even like let's say you
don't want this meta
yeah you don't want this information
right here i can just take this off
okay now we don't need to see like when
it was posted and who created it
or you may not want to show tags i don't
have any tags but at the bottom would
show tags if there were tags
but one thing we you may want to do is
decide
which meta information shows up like for
instance maybe you don't want to show
the categories down here i'm going to
take off categories
so now we don't need to know it was
reviews
and maybe you probably maybe you don't
want to show how many comments there are
okay you just want to show the author
and then
the date
or maybe you don't even want to show the
author maybe everything is going to be
created by the same person so you don't
need to show who the author was for each
post remember the author that's how we i
showed you how to create different
accounts so the author is whatever
account made that post
okay let's call this good there's a lot
more settings you can do if you want but
i'm just going to publish this
okay now while we're looking at this
if you were going to use this as your
real page you wouldn't want all these
sample articles there's all these sample
blog posts and there's all these sample
comments just so you can see what it's
going to look like you're not going to
want those sample
articles and comments and blog posts
when you actually go live with your
website so let's see how to remove those
i'll go to the dashboard and i'll go to
posts and then i'm just going to select
all the posts except i'm going to
unselect the one they just created and
now bulk actions and move to trash so
these are all just the demo posts
and then we can do the same thing with
the comments let's go to comments
and actually the comments just got
automatically deleted because they were
already associated with those blog posts
that we just deleted
so we don't even have to delete the
comments anymore
and now let's go to our site just let's
see what it looks like right now if i
click on reviews or just one there's no
recent comments and there's zero
comments on this one
so you can go and see what that looks
like
good and people could leave a comment
maybe i'll leave a comment right now
this is a great
post
now you may not want people to be able
to leave a post or leave leave a comment
so let me show you how you would turn
off comments completely on your posts
i'm gonna go to customize here
then we'll go to blog
single post
go down here
and then i can just hide comments so now
nobody's gonna be able to comment
nobody's going to be able to
see account see comments or leave a
comment so now we just don't even have
to worry about comments if you're going
to do that you're probably going to want
to remove this section here recent
comments so let's just remove that so we
don't show the recent comments let's
publish
okay and let's just do a preview again
so here are the reviews it's not going
to show recent comments let's see if we
can search for something
so i searched for a robot and it came up
with all the pages that have robot not
just the blog post but also the other
pages so that's pretty nice
okay so now we are going to figure out
how to update this contact us page
i'm just gonna go to edit with elementor
and so just like before to update the
map i'm gonna click this here i'm gonna
type in michigan
and then i'm going to zoom out a little
bit here
looks nice and you can put in an exact
address if you want
you could also just delete this whole
section if you just right click on here
i could go to delete down here
but we're not going to do that so now
what you're going to want to do is just
change the colors here so go to style
and then
primary and then obviously you would
change your the address to be your
address so we could change this style
to primary
and then these hours we can change this
to primary
or you may not want these at all you may
want a contact form on this page
so we're going to add a contact form
right now where people can fill that out
and then send an email to you so let me
put a plus here
and then it says wp form just going to
drag this in
okay it says you can use wp forms to
build a contact form surveys payment
forms and more with just a few clicks
let's create a form
you can create it for completely from
scratch or start with the template i'm
just going to use simple contact form
okay name first name last name email
commenter message let's say you also
want to drop down
and the drop down let's say it's going
to be
subject
and then you have a few different
choices maybe it can be
robot review
programming
lessons
site
suggestion
or
other
okay we can decide if it's going to be
required or not we'll make this not
required
that looks pretty good so we have the
name field the email the subject and the
comment or message and then there's a
submit form
okay if we go to settings and then we go
to confirmations
we can
put what's going to happen once someone
submits the message so thanks for
contacting us
robots
[Music]
are
amazing then we'll do oops not add new
confirmation we're just going to use
this one confirmation and then we'll
save this
i will go out of this
we got this form so now the form is
right on the page so what's going to
happen when you click submit well it's
going to send an email to whatever email
you have set up
in your settings in your wordpress
settings so let me show you how you
would confirm that let's see how you
would confirm your wordpress settings so
let me
update click update button down here
now preview changes we'll just see what
the form looks like really quick first
so here's the form and you can select
the subject let's go to our dashboard
then we'll put settings general
okay so we have the email address
bowatfreecodecamp.org
so this email address should get a an
email if someone fills out the form
let's test that
i'm going to go to contact us
and i'm going to put
name quincy
larson
quincy
at free code camp.org
i'll do site suggestion
update your footer
and i'll click submit
okay thanks for contacting us robots are
amazing okay let me go into my email and
see if i can find that email
and here's the email now it did get
marked as potential spam but since i
basically had it sent to myself i know
it's not a spam so you can say look safe
and you can see name email subject and
then the command message update your
footer oh that's a good idea quincy
thanks i should update the footer okay
so that worked we can now our contact
form works
okay let's go back to our page
so now that we have the contact form
let's go back to edit with elementor
person i don't want to deal with people
calling me or actually coming to my
house or anything
so this contact page i just want to have
the contact form so i'm going to delete
this section so now i'll just have the
map and then the contact form and that's
pretty good so let's take quincy's
suggestion and update the footer now
but we're going to also update this
little header too i'm going to show you
how to update this line up here and then
the footer down here okay so let's first
preview
okay and now to update this header here
and then we'll update the footer we're
going to go to customize
okay so this thing right here is called
the top bar and this part right here is
called the header and so we can update
the top bar or the header let's so let's
go to top bar go to general
and we could just disable it completely
that's maybe one thing we want to do
disable the top bar i kind of think that
looks good like that we don't really
need to show a phone number or these
social icons but let's say you do want
to
show them so let's go to enable top bar
and then we can see well do we want to
hide it on mobile or hide on tablet or
just show on all devices we can change
the colors we can change different
colors different paddings but let's go
back here for the content and right now
the content is call us at this phone
number
but maybe you want some sort of call to
action
like check
out our new programming
lessons
and then let's say we want to change
these social icons at the end
you could just disable them completely
or we can able them and just enable just
have certain ones
so you can see there's all these options
and if you put a hash mark that's just
an empty link if you if you don't have
anything it won't show up on here so
let's we're not going to have skype
we won't have linkedin
we won't have instagram let's say we
only want twitter and youtube
so now it's just twitter and youtube and
we can actually just put our twitter
page we can put our youtube page right
here whatever we type in here like if i
say https
colon slash slash youtube.com
freecodecamp
and let's say
publish
and we'll put that so now if you click
here the youtube button so now it opens
up the free codecamp youtube channel
let's close that
okay so now we know how to update this
and then i already kind of showed you
how to update this
header i just showed you where you would
click but let me just show you a few of
the options you can do for that
so click header
we can change the height
we can
change the background color
maybe you want it darker but we'll just
go back to default
wait
default
and then there's just a bunch of other
things you can change here and just
making the you can change update your
logo
the menu
the mobile menu because
when it's a mobile device is going to
look different so i already kind of
showed you that
but yeah you can click mobile i'll show
you what it's going to look like when
you're when it's a mobile device
and
you can click the menu and that's what
the menu is going to look like as a
mobile device
okay let's go back to this okay so we
know about editing the top bar the menu
now let's go down to the footer here
there's a lot of stuff in that footer a
lot of stuff we're not actually going to
need
so there's two sections there's this
section which are called the footer
widgets
and then there's this copier this bottom
bar called footer bottom so let's update
the footer bottom first
it's just going to say
copyright and you may not want to say
oceanwp theme by nick maybe you just
want to take that off
maybe we just want copyright
2001.
and then these links down here are going
to be the footer menu which i'll show
you later but we got this footer bottom
updated and you may want to update the
footer widgets
so here we can update the color and
everything and some general things but
another what thing you can do is just
click on this like you may not have a
newsletter
so this is set up if you do have a
newsletter you can actually set up to
work with mailchimp now it takes a
little bit of a bit more setup
and for now it's it's kind of outside
what we want to do so i'm going to
remove that
we already have our social at the top we
don't need them at the bottom so let's
just remove the social
it works the same way as the stuff at
the top
and now i don't think we need this
practice areas too so we just want to
have the contact us we just want about
us and the contact info so i'm going to
remove this again and now we just have
these two columns but it kind of looks
weird that they're squished so let's
make these so they fill up the whole
thing so let's go back to the footer
actually wait footer footer widgets
and i'm going to do two columns there
should only be two columns here
okay we have two columns we're not
seeing both columns so what we can do
actually is go to the widgets section
here
okay let's go to footer widgets and
let's do
okay we have three columns here
we just want two columns
you
so we're gonna go to two columns here
and it looks like we lost one so to get
that back we're gonna go to widgets
footer two well see footer one is how we
would update the about us let me show
you that and then we'll add the second
one back
so this is how you would update the
about us you can say
we write
the best robot reviews
and you can update this
check out
our
reviews
see this p just means paragraph the
beginning of the paragraph to enter the
paragraph the beginning of the paragraph
to enter the paragraph and now you can
see a means anchor tag or it's just a
link so first footer so this is a link
and then this is the second link
the link goes nothing we don't have an
about us page so we're gonna take this
whole
section off
and then we're just going to have the
contact us page and again we're going to
go to the same page we keep going to so
that would be
robotfamilyreviews.com
contact
so now this button will go to the
contact page
okay i'll click done
and then we'll add the second footer
section and i can do add widget now i
can there's all these different things
you can add as the widget
an image gallery
a page
calendar
audio twitter
but we're going to add a contact info
for the widget
and you can see that it has all this
information here but it's not showing up
if you just change something in here
like i could say
contact
us today
then it's going to show up sometimes you
just have to change the text to make it
show up
and then you can update the street the
phone so we can actually modify some of
this stuff like we don't need so many
phone numbers we're just
so let's say we only want the mobile
phone number so we can just basically if
you just delete
everything here
it will go away and so we don't want fax
i don't know if there's too many people
that use fax anymore
and then we can
keep the email address
which is going to be bo
at free
code camp.org
and then we just duplicate that
and a website well where are people
already on the website so we don't need
to share that there
okay and you could change the address
too and then we have these this button
here now for skype we don't want that
and that's what we want so i'm going to
click publish up here
okay and i can close this
and we got our website
so now i'm just going to show you how
you change this menu down here
so to do that we have to go
into our dashboard
then we'll go to appearance
and then we'll go to menus
and then we go to footer menu
select
now
so you can change which links
you have here so let's say what if i
want my programming lessons in here i
can add that to the menu here
and then
if i can actually just delete some of
these other things so remove
remove
remove
and if you didn't want to remove it you
can just change it you would have to
update the url and then what the label
is
but i'll just save the menu and let's
see what it looks like with just that
one item so i'm gonna go to the site
and you can see it just says programming
lessons
that looks kind of weird so
let's just remove the menu altogether
and then i'll show you how to update
this this should show like an up arrow
if because it navigates to the top of
the page but right now it's just a
box here but let's remove that menu
first so i'm just going to go to the
dashboard
close these extra tabs
and then i'll go to appearance menus
and
i'm just going to delete the menu
and then save that let me go back to the
site
okay now we don't have the menu and then
let's update the copyright notice
copyright 2001.
i think i typed that in earlier
incorrectly so i can go to customize
a footer bottom
and then that should be
copyright 2000
21. now let's change with this button we
this i said we get back to this where we
change that button so it's blue there
so i've already showed you a few places
where you can update colors
and if you see something on your page in
your theme and you cannot figure out how
you can change the color of that item
it could be in the custom css js tab so
if you go here this is a little tricky
to update because you are going to need
to know a little bit about css but
you don't have to know a lot you may be
able to figure this out and if you don't
want to even bother with it you can
always just delete this button and we
don't even need a button in the about us
page but
if you really want to try to figure out
how you can change this you can look for
some comments so anything like this is a
comment
and we can see this as button in the
footer so we know this is probably
something that's going to change any
buttons that are in the footer and then
remember we know that the anything that
looks like this these are colors these
are the hex colors that we saw before
and you can see oh color and then it has
this so what i'm going to do is just
paste in that blue color from before we
have this hack so i'm just going to
paste in that color
and then it changes to the right color
so we can click publish
and that worked
so i'm going to go back
and the last thing i need to do is
update this thing right here this should
be an arrow
okay so to update this we're going to go
to general options then scroll to top
and then we're just going to select what
we want to look like
and so i'm just going to create this two
arrows but you can also ch there's a lot
of other settings you can change on that
and then you can also turn it off if you
don't like it you can just turn off the
button and actually you think i i think
i'm just going to go with turning it off
completely and i'll go with publish
and then this let's test out the site
okay
obviously there's more things we can
update but
i think you really know everything for
all the things you have to do to update
the site
okay we've reached the end you should
now know how to create your own
wordpress website and customize it to
meet your needs